hey what is up guys i'm kim Bhd here and
I kind of already warned you but we
can't leave all the hype for this year
for just one phone so this is another I
don't know if you've seen this already
or if you haven't but this is the iPhone
7 plus model so obviously we're
expecting an iPhone 7 to be announced
and released probably around September
of this year and we kind of already know
all of the new software features because
iOS 10 beta has been floating around and
people have been using it for the past
couple weeks I did a video showing all
the new features at WWDC but what we
don't have yet and what's going to be
announced is a new hardware so there's
been rumors of a new iphone 7 pro or an
iPhone 7 plus along with an iPhone 7
whatever you want to call it this is
more than just like a render from a
computer of an image of what it might
look like this is an actual dummy unit
put together based on all the leaks and
rumors of what the iPhone 7 plus is
going to look like and feel like in the
hand made of metal and everything so
let's take a closer look at well you'll
notice there's three main features that
are visibly new about the iPhone 7 and 7
plus based on this body 1 the antenna
lines to the headphone jack or lack
thereof and 3 the dual cameras so the
antenna lines are pretty much the only
aesthetic or visual change between this
year's iPhone and the new one we're
about to get so this year's antenna vans
go all the way across and around the top
and the bottom
this year it's looking like it's just
the top in the bottom and nothing across
the back looks cleaner to me I guess
didn't really have a problem with the
band's but this is fine I guess this
might be one of those things where it's
the only way you can tell someone has
the new iPhone unless there's a new
color which there might be number 2 is
the headphone jack or the lack thereof
you probably already saw this video
earlier but yeah the rumors still point
to Apple getting rid of the headphone
jack in the next iPhone so this model
has no such port what you do get though
which is interesting is now 2 speaker
grilles which I'm going to be optimistic
and hope that that means stereo speakers
like the iPads now it's very possible
that this may just be another speaker
grille for a single speaker but I'm
going to be optimistic I'm hoping they
use a space to put in another driver
please give a stereo audio anyway last
but not
you can see the dual camera module on
the back so all right at this point
that's all we really know about it like
we know that it'll have two cameras but
we don't know what they will do or we
don't know if they will be the same or
different
I made an entire video all about dual
camera smartphones already so I'll link
that below but there are some that
already have one wide angle and one
normal smartphone camera that you can
switch between there are smartphones
that have two of the same camera that
combine the image to get more detail we
don't know what Apple is doing with the
iPhone 7 plus but we're pretty sure it
will at least be rockin the dual camera
setup you may have also noticed that
this mock-up does not have the couple of
smart connector pins that we have seen
on some other mock-ups and this actually
relates to the rumor that we may see an
iphone 7 pro which will connect to some
accessories like the iPad pro via those
smart connector pins and then this which
is just an iPhone 7 plus doesn't have
the pins and then we can also assume a
regular sized iPhone 7 also won't have
those pins overall though pretty similar
design to iPhone 6 and iPhone 6s that we
already have you know same rounded shape
same thickness same button placement you
know same switches bezels the home
button everything is super similar
already about the overall design I'm
gonna go out on a limb and say I'm
hoping I'm just hoping that something
that we haven't seen in any of the
mock-ups or in any of the leaks is a new
display on the front of the iPhone I
feel like they could double the
resolution of the display and I feel
like they could also finally incorporate
an OLED display in the iPhone 7 and 7
plus now that's obviously we won't be
able to tell this from the mock-ups we
can't tell this from the dummy units but
I feel like it's about time we give the
bigger iPhone a much nicer screen anyway
that's pretty much it just a short video
obviously not a whole ton that you can
learn from the dummy units and mock-ups
from the rumours we've already seen but
it's just kind of neat to have the
actual form factor in person and just
see what it would look like if you were
to hold it in the hand either way let me
know what you guys would think if you're
into this design new design of the
iPhone 7 or if you would have liked some
other features or something else let me
know in the comments section right below
that like button that's pretty much it
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
guys the next one peace
you